this in the next episode Steve Urkel
turns Carl into a giant sandwich and
accidentally eats him Zima this was
supposed to be about me and my family oh
but you know after that first despot
Steve Urkel I mean America fell in love
man we had to make him a regular and you
know listen he's the star of the show
now sweetheart we got a play ball
bubbeleh
don't you dare bubbeleh me gene now last
week Steve used his transformation
machine to turn Carl into a car and
drive him around the Monaco Grand Prix
come on how many times are gonna use
this transformation machine this is
supposed to be a blue-collar Cosby Show
now you turn it into goddamn quantum
leap all right I couldn't tell you even
if I wanted to okay baby we got like 21
writers up there K'naan say original but
you and I both know but they don't
decide what happens to the show okay we
both know two weeks ago Steve Urkel uses
invisibility ray on Carl and I was owed
it was just my voice just you know I
know that's when I'm sorry I apologize
will never happen again
Dan Steve used his voice-changing ray to
turn Carl into a high-pitched nerdy
voice who do you think provided a voice
for that don't get too feisty on me now
reg let's not go down that path okay oh
we're going down that path gene in a
couple of weeks Harriet Eddie Laura
grandma Aunt Rachel little Richie and
the other little kid are gonna get
teleported to another dimension and then
Steve injects Carl with his own DNA so
Carl turns into another Steve Urkel
that's two Steve Urkel's and no family
on a show called family matters ha does
that work listen listen Reginald
herckel Mania is unstoppable okay he
said phenomenon there's nothing we can
do about okay it's up no no no no
Richard absurd
I was in true West with Sherman Hemsley
I was in die hard damn it
Steve Urkel you are suck Steve Urkel's
everyone to to who you all suck it to
understand here's our bread and butter
you mother
okay cocaine than you weigh mother I'm
gonna tell you what you are Russell
veljohnson you're a pawn in that nerds
game you are a pawn do you think I have
any power over what that monster does
any power at all I am the senior vice
president of development for the
American bro Jane Jane Jane what's
become of you gene
I am nothing
Gina I don't know what you mean I've had
to make you scare me no no no don't do
anything crazy team everyone does too
much coke sometimes but just what are
you gonna do it the gun gene what are
you gonna do then no no no no we can
talk this through okay the king is dead
long live the king
did I do that
[Music]
Dalila Jalil there is no Jalil only
Steve it's always been Steve forgetting
something Carl don't you come near me
stay away from me ya could have all been
so simple Carl just say your behinds and
take the money
Tomas
what are you doing I can't control
doing this no no no no no no no I'll do
anything do what I want on family
matters of course see you on set Carl
[Applause]
you